hi everyone so I've been wanting to make
this video for a long time and I've been
thinking about it a lot lately so I want
to talk about what a famous 18th century
mathematician the personal computer the
US economy the spread of disease and the
bunny population on earth all have in
common and so many of you have probably
figured out that I'm talking about
exponential growth an exponential growth
is a ubiquitous phenomenon in planet
Earth on planet earth and in the
universe at large so many many many
processes are governed by exponential
growth and I've decided that in this
short lecture series I'm going to talk
about exponential growth this is the
overview and I'm gonna walk you through
what you're gonna see ok so I think that
this is just a fascinating theory it
ties a lot of my absolute favorite
topics together from number theory and
kind of you know population dynamics to
differential equations it's very
relevant today I know a lot of us have
been thinking about disease spread with
covin 19 you know lots and lots and lots
of systems are governed by exponential
growth and so that's what we're going to
talk about I'm Steve Brunton you can
find more updates at IgAN Steve on
Twitter and I'm going to walk you
through kind of the overview of what
you're gonna see in this short series on
exponential growth so economic growth is
one of the major areas that you know you
can see exponential exponential pattern
so I'm going to show you some examples
and then I'm going to give you an
overview of what we're gonna see so this
is a plot of the long-term growth of the
US GDP the gross domestic product this
is not the stock market the stock
market's much more volatile but this is
the actual gross kind of production of
the US over time for about a hundred
years and you can see that this is very
nearly exponential even given the Great
Depression and recessions and stock
market crash
is this is very you know exponential in
time so economic growth is one area
another really really important area
where exponential growth comes in is in
Moore's law of increasing computer power
so computers are built up out and of
transistors and Moore's law saz roughly
speaking that the number of transistors
doubles every two years so that we get
more and more powerful computers as time
goes on I mean this has been central in
in in the modern technological era okay
so I'm actually gonna do a whole video
on Moore's law I'm also gonna do a whole
series on Epidemiology and the spread of
disease and this is for example the
flatten the curve of Cova 19 plot and
for short times you see that virus is
spreading through a population spread
exponentially and then eventually as
enough of that population is infected it
stops being exponential and this is a
really important point that I'm gonna
I'm going to make a lot of attention and
given a lot of attention to is this idea
that lots and lots of systems grow
exponentially for a while but eventually
there's always something that stops that
system from keeping growing
exponentially always there's some reason
why that system saturates or why some
effect stops it from growing
exponentially and so I'll make the claim
that exponential growth doesn't actually
really exist forever in any system we
have a finite world and a finite
population and you can't grow
exponentially forever
okay so we're going to look at kind of
different processes that give rise to
exponential growth an exponential decay
so I'm going to talk about you know the
classic population growth so if you have
two bunnies one year you'll have four
bunnies the next you'll have eight
bunnies the next and so on and so forth
similarly with radioactive decay if I
have you know something that has a
half-life of one year if I have 40 grams
this year I'll have 20 grams next year
and so on and so forth so we'll go
through some examples of systems that
have exponential growth an exponential
decay like compound interest in the bank
is a really good example I will also
have a video on why this is actually
called exponential growth so we're gonna
actually go back through history and
look at oiler and Euler's number II and
how we can derive kind of formulas for
this exponential growth and how it
relates to differential equations and
again anything with Euler you know it's
a big deal so that's that's gonna be
kind of fun okay so we're gonna talk
about systems that have exponential
growth we're going to talk about why
it's called exponential growth we're
also going to look at why exponential
growth always must end so even though
you know your bunny population would
grow exponentially because we have a
finite earth or a finite you know
neighborhood or whatever something is
going to cause this exponential growth
to eventually saturate okay it might be
finite resources it might also be
predators so talking about predator prey
models and how the existence of wolves
that eat bunnies also you know stops the
system from growing exponentially
forever so that's also stuff we're going
to talk about I'm also going to talk a
little bit about si our models disease
models and how again we know that
infections do grow exponentially for a
time but there are always extra factors
in the model that caused the exponential
growth to eventually saturate and taper
off okay so we're going to talk about
this in the context of disease models
too and I think based on this idea that
exponential growth is everywhere it is
just ubiquitous in lots and lots of
systems from you know radioactive
systems bunny population systems the
financial sector disease spread you name
it you know hopefully YouTube
subscribers grow exponentially and the
more base you have or social media grows
exponentially the larger the base you
have the more people see it and the
faster you know the more exposure okay
so lots and lots of systems are
exponential but again because these
exponential systems can't grow forever
there's huge implications so I'm also
going to talk about kind of the
technological implications of
exponential growth
in transportation in computers in
artificial intelligence and machine
learning and some takeaways for you know
us as humans okay so this is something
I've been wanting to do for a long time
I'm really excited about talking about
exponential growth and we're gonna kind
of break it down into a few key topics
all right thank you